well as we increasingly suspected the
leak of the supreme court roe v wade
decision increasingly appears to have
been leaked
by right wingers in order to
ensure that roe v wade was overturned we
have a new report from rolling stone it
is absolutely fascinating and we are
going to talk about it but let me kind
of reset the story for you
when that decision leaked
there was the immediate reaction from
the right
that this was a left winger who leaked
the decision to pressure justices to
vote to preserve roe v wade in order to
intimidate them and much of the reason
for that was that left wingers were
rightly outraged that the supreme court
planned to overturn roe v wade so the
right said it was a left winger who did
the leaking we've got to investigate it
we got to figure out who it is people
should be fired disbarred if they're
lawyers whatever
now
i took the approach of if we're just
speculating could have been a left wing
or could have been a right winger uh
there were two scenarios one
potential scenario would be
the leaker was on the left
knew that the draft would overturn roe v
wade and thought that by leaking it it
might generate a pressure campaign to
get a supreme court justice or two to
change their minds and vote to preserve
roe v wade
just as plausibly
the leaker could have been a right
winger who was aware that while this
draft would have overturned roe v wade
the february draft that was leaked in
you know a few months after that
they may have known that within the
court
there may have been justices changing
their minds and the idea was to leak the
draft to publicize who as of february
planned to overturn roe v wade to make
it difficult for them to change their
minds these were the two speculative
scenarios and over time as republicans
stopped talking about investigating the
leaker as we heard from long-time
supreme court reporters that within the
supreme court the belief was actually
that the leaker was a right winger i
started to be of the mindset that the
leaker was probably a right winger well
we now know from a new report that that
appears to be correct john roberts was
lobbying kavanaugh to save roe
then the draft opinion leaked a new
report says the leak which conservatives
insist was the work of a rogue liberal
actually helped get roe overturned this
was exactly the opinion that i told you
months ago
was the most likely
immediately after the draft supreme
court decision was released
conservatives began bleeding about how
the leak was the work of a nefarious
liberal clerk who wanted to put the
opinion out to pressure the court's
conservatives to change their minds it's
possible that that's what happened but
if so publicizing the draft had the
opposite effect according to a new
report from cnn per the report the leak
of the draft decision foiled chief
justice roberts attempts to persuade
brett kavanaugh to act as roe's saving
vote
sources told cnn roberts continued to
try and sway the junior justice even
after the leak of the opinion despite
public and private pressure from
conservatives for the court to solidify
its decision robert's overtures this
spring particularly to kavanaugh raised
fears among conservatives and hopes
among liberals that the chief would
change the outcome in the most closely
watched case in decades now you might
remember
roberts ultimately voted to uphold the
mississippi law that was disputed but he
did a separate
uh concurrence
disagreeing with the decision to strike
down roe so i know a lot of you might be
saying but david the math doesn't work
because roberts did vote to uphold dobbs
and the belief is
based on what he wrote and based on
everything that's being reported roberts
wanted to uphold dobbs
but still maintain roe v wade and was
working on kavanaugh to do the same
this is
exactly what it increasingly seemed like
within about eight or ten days of the
leaked decision
and this thinking provides support for
the belief that the leaker was a right
wing staffer they wanted to prevent
brett kavanaugh from defecting that's
fundamentally what it is
and this is probably why we never heard
it how is the search going for the real
killer oj what do we know right it's the
same type of thing we're going to
investigate oh it was one of ours yeah
let's just never mention that
investigation again and it's very funny
and also kind of disturbing how in the
days immediately following the leak
everybody was saying the right wing
apparatus was saying what a travesty
what a miscarriage of justice this is
criminal people need to be charged
people need to be disbarred these
left-wingers leaking this stuff and then
we never hear about it again and to be
perfectly frank the dead giveaway was
that the right and conservative media
went silent about the investigation and
the leaker about a week or 10 days after
the leak took place somebody maybe
tipped them off and said don't don't
even talk about this the leaker was one
of ours or not even just don't talk
about this
don't say more about the investigation
and that's what the report is and it's
exactly what we and many of you believed
at the time